على مدار السنوات الماضيه اخذت السينما
السعوديه تتصاعد في حركتها الانتاجيه
والنوعيه الامر الذي بات واضحه من خلال
الكم والنوع المنتج من الافلام كذلك زاد
الاهتمام في السنوات الاخيره بدور العرض
فضلا عن رفع سوق الانتاج السعودي الفلمي
وكذلك تنظيم العديد من المهرجانات
السينمائيه اليوم يبدو ان المملكه ستكون
في السنوات القليله المقبله احد اكبر
منتجيه الافلام السينمائيه العربيه خصوصا
مع انباعنيتها انتاج اكثر من 100 فيلم حتى
عام 20/3 افلام نساء ترسخ دور المملكه
الاعلامي ومكانتها كم مركز الاعلام وسينما
في الشرق الاوسط مع زياده الميزانيه
المنوطه بعمليه التطوير هذا والجدير
بالذكر فالافلام قوه ثقافيه ناعمه وصناعه
لها لحضور عالمي فكيف غيرت الافلام
السياحه وثقافه والاقتصاد في دول العالم
تفاصيل معك علم
من اهم مكونات الهيمنه الثقافيه والقوه
الناعمه للولايات المتحده بلا شك هي
هوليود التي تتحكم في قائمه اكثر الافلام
تحقيقا للايرادات وتوفر اكثر من مليونين
وظيفه في نيوزيلندا اجريت دراسه
الاستقصائيه حكوميه عام 2004 بعد اصدار
الجزء الثالث والاخير من ذا لورد اوف ذا
رينسنس ووجدت ان 6% من الزوار اختاروا
نيوزيلندا كوجاتهم السياحيه اعتمادا على
السلسله
السينما النيجيريه اكثر من 600 مليون
دولار سنويا في الاقتصاد بل وحلت محل
الافلام الامريكيه في كثير من الدول
الافريقيه بخلاف دورها في تغيير الصوره
النمطيه السلبيه عن مواطن نيجيريا مثال
اخر على تاثير السينمات قوه ناعمه فبعد
اصدار فيلم روما على منصه والذي فاز بافضل
فيلم اجنبيه عام 2019 اصبح حي روما الذي
صورت فيه مشاهد الفيلم في المكسيك وجهه
سياحيه عصريه يجذب الاف السياح سنويا
واخيرا فيلم باراسايد اول فيلم غير ناطق
بالانجليزيه يحقق جائزه افضل فيلم في
هوليود قفز بصناعه السينما الكوريه الى
السماء وهو ما ترجمه نجاح مسلسل لعبه
الحبار الذي اصبح اكثر الاعمال مشاهده على
منصه
السلام عليكم سعيده جدا بحضوركم الليله
طبعا اغلبكم يعرفوني زين وتعرفون سبب
وجودي
[موسيقى]
سي طارق اهلا بك يسعد صباحك منورنا صباح
العربيه السعوديه
والنوعيه في المملكه سينمائيه
صباح الخير جميعا تحيه لك وساده المشاهدين
اااه اعتقد انه هذا الاتجاه
يعبر عن رغبه كبيره جدا في التعبير هناك
الكثير من القصص والمواضيع والهواجس
والافكار التي تحيط بكل لسان في العالم
فاعتقد ان هذه فكره مهمه جدا للتعبير عن
المجتمع السعودي وعن
تضلعات المستقبل واعتقدوا ان السينما
واحده من ادوات المهمه جدا للتعبير في
العصر الحديث هي همم قد تكون عمرها 100
عام لكن ما زالت حاضره ومهمه جدا ولها
كثير من المتابعين المهتم من حول العالم
طيب طارق اليوم لفتره طويله يعني كان
العرب يصورون في الافلام الغربيه بطريقه
سلبيه ودائما البطل هو الغربي طالما نحن
لدينا الامكانيات ولدينا الموارد هل نحن
نفتقر ربما للقدره والامكانيه على تصوير
انفسنا بالشكل اللازم والشكل الكافي
للعالم
همم اعتقد انه يعني هو سؤال دائما عن من
يعبر عن الاخر بطريقه افضل ودائما هو كما
يقولون يعني كان يقول تحدث حتى اعرف يعني
فاذا همم قدمنا افلام غالب سوف يصنع
العالم عندك تصورات معينه ال- فكره التصور
عن نفسك هي لا تاتي من فيلم او فيلمين
ولكن من التراكم معين الافلام
الكوريه سينما الايرانيه وهي ليست من خلال
كلمه من خلال تراكم معين صار على هذه
السينما سمعتها واصبحت بشكل تعبر عن هذه
القوميات فانا اعتقد انه العالم العربيه
بسواني يعني من الانتاجات المصريه المبكره
وكذلك كثير من اعمال السينمائيه المميزه
التي خرجت مثلا من المغرب العربي ولا من
لبنان ولا من همم يعني همم
يعني مختلفه بالعالم العربي عبر بشكل
مختلف عن هويات متعدده واعتقد انه كان
ايضا السعوديه
واعتقد انه هذه تضم ضمن اشيائه اخرى بدات
تشير ببناء العالم العربي يعني بالامس
اكثر ان الملف كاس العالم في قطر واعتقد
ان هذا قدم صوره مختلفه وايجابيا العرب
اليوم لبست اصبح يعني له حضور كبير جدا
بسبب يعني خلينا نقول فكره معينه فاعتقد
انه مثل هذا النوع من ال ال ال التوجه الى
العالم من خلال الصوره سيكون له فائده
كبيره جدا في تصوير العرب طيب سي طارق
شاهدنا في السعوديه زياده كبيره في
ميزانيه
الانتاج السينمائي وزياده الانتاج
السينمائي السعودي للافلام السعوديه
تحديدا لكن السؤال ما هي ابرز التحديات
التي قد تواجه العمل سينمائي في السعوديه
خصوصا مع الطموح لان تتصدر السينما
العربيه
يعني انا اعتقد انه في هذا المرحله مهم
جدا ان نستوعب ان نحن في مرحله متقدمه جدا
من السينما وليس هناك مجال ولا مساحه ان
ينتظر الاخر تطور هذه الصناعه سينمائيه في
السعوديه حتى تصبح موازيه يجب ان نفذ
قفزات كبيره جدا حتى نصل لجذب الانتباه
بمعنى انه لن يلتفت الناس الى افلام التي
ستنتجها المملكه ما لم تكون افلام جيده
مكتوبه بعنايه منفذه باحترافيه انتاج جيد
وتمثيل واداء يعني يكون على قدر المستوى
الذي يجذب الاخرين ولذلك انا اعتقد ان نحن
لسنا في مرحله فيلم سعودي جيد وانما يجب
علينا ان نذهب الى مرحله فيلم جيد هيك طيب
فيلم جيد طارق هل ستتحقق الرؤيا السعوديه
المطلوبه بانتاج فعلا بحلول عام 20 30 هل
كل الامكانيات موجوده هل المواهب الكوادر
والموارد متوفره بالشكل الكافي والكامل
يعني على السبيل الدعم مثلا هناك عده
مؤسسات في المملكه العربيه السعوديه تدعم
بشكل كبير جدا نتاج الافلام هناك كوادر
سواء وطنيه او عربيه قادره على انها يعني
تعمل مع بعض لتحقيق هذا الانجاح يعني هذا
الرقم اللي يبدو الى الان يعني انه رقم
كبير جدا وكذلك اعتقد انه في استديوهات
وفي عرض وفي جمهور يشاهد في مهرجانات
سينما في السعوديه في مهرجان افلام سعوديه
بمنطقه الشرقيه ومهرجان الاحمر في جده
واعتقدنا هذه التقدم الى برامج دعم برامج
لتطويل السناري وبرامج لتطوير الافلام
وايضا فيها برامج اللي ما بعد الانتاج
فانا اعتقد انه هذه كلها ستعمل بشكل كبير
جدا في انها تساعد هناك اقسام الدراسيه في
جامعه الان اصبح مخصصه للسينما وهناك ايضا
بنيه تحت يعني تطور بشكل كبير جدا همم
قاعدين يقدمون اماكن للتصوير مع يعني
تسهيلات كبيره جدا للانتاج سنه معي فاعتقد
ان هذه مع مع جمله الانتاجات وجمله عفوا
المبادرات التي تخرج من هناك ستساعد بشكل
كبير جدا في الوصول الى
هذا واحنا بنشكرك جزيه للشكر يا طارق من
الرياض ناقد سينمائي طارق خواجي شكرا لك